[Music]
lauren is with us in oklahoma city hi
lauren welcome to the ramsay show
hi there how's it going better than i
deserve what's up
just a quick question on what your ideas
opinion's input is on
uh following a passion job versus
financial security stability uh
essentially chasing the money i'm 42
years old i have a double income with my
wife
we have two kids
uh very little debt about 50 000 total
debt including a vehicle and medical
debts
i
just started a couple months ago going
back to school
to begin to become a teacher
uh
why this will introduce new debt why uh
essentially to follow a passion i
started school
uh i graduated high school and your
passion is to be a teacher in the
classroom or to teach yep or to teach to
be a teacher in a classroom because i'm
a teacher
okay but i didn't take a pay cut
right right essentially this hopefully
would get me
uh better stability and job uh not
necessarily higher income though it
would be a
bump
based on where i teach and whatnot but
uh yeah what do you make now
uh roughly 35.
and what would you make in the classroom
uh about 45 to 60. if you're gonna make
multiple again depending on where i
teach yeah you're gonna make more than
you make now
right i thought you were saying you
would have to go down an income to work
your passion no no no it would it would
be a bump in income oh okay why would
you not do
it it would it would introduce more debt
oh well just go get your teaching
certificate without going into debt pay
cash for it
uh a little tough no it's not
it's called work lauren the way you
phrased up your debt initially you said
oh we just have a little bit of debt
just 50 grand so it tells me you're
broke
how is it a little debt if you can't
afford to cash flow school because of it
right we we essentially live paycheck to
paycheck um
uh we have
what's your life what's your wife work
what's that what's your wife make
about 33 000 okay so you have a
68 000 household income which is the
average household income in america
how much is your car payment
uh 4
400 or 398 a month sell your car and we
have about 22 000
left on the loan show your car
you're not gonna do that i could tell by
the way you answered that
see here's the thing
you've got it in your head that you get
to do all of these things at once keep a
car you can't afford go get a degree you
can't afford
what meanwhile making the excuse of we
live paycheck to paycheck and that's an
excuse it's not a fact
right sell your stinking car get three
extra jobs go to the community college
and get your teaching certificate and
pay cash for your teaching certificate
and live your dream with no additional
debt
by the way when you sell your car cut
your debt in half
right that would
something for you to think about dude i
don't know if you're going to do it or
not because i think you got this all
figured out in your head that you want
to go be normal the way you're
describing is normal but i'll help you
with this normal sucks
you're getting ready to keep a 22 000
car you can't afford and go get a degree
and put another 25 or 30 000 on top of
this and get a 10 000 bump and you're
gonna then you're gonna wind the
teachers don't make enough
what i'm hearing is we're already 50
grand in debt what's another 20 30 40 to
get this well it's just this mindset
that this is normal and it's the only
way to do it well it's not the only way
to do it i'll guarantee you you can work
overtime you can work extra jobs and you
can go to the cheapest possible
local university
community college whatever it is you got
to do to finish up your work to get your
teaching certificate and i want you to
go be a teacher i just don't want you to
be dumb about it
because i it's just going to cost you
it's going to cost you a decade of your
life doing this wrong and it really has
to do with this stupid car it has to do
with you not being willing to sacrifice
and dial this down instead you're just
kind of going the easy way and the easy
way is always not the easy way
it's always the hard way and the truth
is even with this bump in income you're
going to be broke again you're not going
to fix the problem there you go because
you've gone up in debt enough that it
sucks up every bit of that new income
and so all the joy from this is going to
be gone